well we're back at it to check out more
vids from spider warren
crazy spider-man no way home plot leak
and trailer news
when i say some people i i know there's
a viewer likes
you keep covering him boy oh boy did i
get a plethora
of messages to check out this one today
i got a lot of messages and i was like
all right people keep watching people
keep asking and we keep enjoying
so yeah we're going to keep going so
yesterday
there was the video about the trailer
update and we said it in our reaction
that we were like
i don't think it's coming on twos it
just didn't make sense to me that it
would come out and then i reached out to
a couple of
people that i know can't cite them i got
a couple of
conflicting reports from them one is
saying it's looking closer to like the
paddington two time
but one who i trust a little bit more is
saying that it's probably closer for the
trailer to come out
towards like the black widow release so
you know either way
it's somewhere here it's somewhere but
let's see what this crazy spider-man no
way home plot leak is
from sir warren
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and of course
spider-man no way home and today we have
an insane plot leak one that actually
sounds
pretty legitimate but one that also
makes me pretty mad
and i think will make a lot of fans mad
as well if this
okay happens that's not what i was
expecting stick around to the end you'll
see why
and i do have an update on that
spider-man no way home trailer but first
big congrats to gabe vlogs for winning
the storm breaker giveaway he's been
contacted and it's on his way to him but
i have
a new giveaway starting very soon that
i'll announce hopefully this week it's
one that i think you guys will really
really like so be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
so let's first talk real quick about the
spider-man no way home trailer and when
to expect it because i got a little bit
more information
over the past couple of days okay for
starters i actually talked to a local
manager at my local
theater and he confirmed that they do
have it
i also talked to some other people i had
a similar conversation but they have
some pretty big contacts and they have
confirmed with these contacts
yes the first teaser trailer is indeed
finished and has been distributed
to theaters i couldn't get an
actual release date but it sounds like
it could happen any day within the next
two weeks from what i understand
they really only send the trailers out
when they're good to go and about to
release to the building
so we are very very close and as always
if i hear
anything else i'll be sure to update
everybody and now we'll start with this
plot leak which again
sounds really really good but i don't
know if i want it
and after you hear the plot lake you'll
all have to let me know what you think
about it in the comments down below so i
can kind of feel the vibe for it but it
sounds very legitimate and of course as
the teaser comes out
and some people have actually seen it we
get more and more leaks so
it could be very legitimate going
through it let's dive right in it says
peter after the identity reveal in
spider-man far from home
ned and mj are with him since their
accomplices to his
crimes and accomplices and crimes are
both in quotes
it then says that doctor strange at
happy's request
finds them in a homeless shelter
undercover where he brings them back to
the sanctum
and tells them to lay low while he
figures out a way to fix everything
there's actually a story in the comic
line where doctor strange mr fantastic
and
iron man actually help erase the memory
of spider-man slash peter parker from
everybody in the world so doctor strange
could definitely figure out a way to fix
this whole identity
crisis but then it goes on to say in the
sanctum
peter comes across a sort of bigger on
the inside
prison where green goblin doc ock and
sandman from the raimi universe
and the lizard and electro from the
amazing spider-man universe are being
held
willem dafoe's green goblin manages to
trick peter into thinking that their
universe's spider-man
were corrupt and killed them it tells
them that peter needs to release them so
they can save their own universes
so peter ends up freeing them and they
escape into the city
it then says that doctor strange then
shows up and tears peter a new one
he explains that he had been holding
them in this prison due to the
instability
in the multiverse connected to each
dimension's oscorp
experimenting with interdimensional
travel
i'm just letting you know that if that
happens already i would be pretty
annoyed
peter come on you're like judgment peter
come on that's all about context and
execution but just being
spat out this way i'm like i could
already see that being kind of but i
don't think that's what warden's talking
about that would be upsetting but let's
see what's going on let's
keep it going and he says that peter has
a responsibility now to stop them
willem dafoe's green goblin leads the
villains to the mcu oscar building to
try and steal prototype interdimensional
technology
peter tries to stop them but he gets his
butt kicked and thrown aside
strange ends up rescuing him and says
that they're going to need more help
and strange and peter travel into the
remyverse and into the amazing
spider-man universe and we see how the
peters are living
after the conclusion of their series
toby mcguire's spider-man is married to
mj and they have a daughter
andrew garfield spider-man is now a
college professor
and i would personally really really
love to see this i would really
love to see toby mcguire's spider-man
with mj having a kid living a
somewhat normal life and andrew garfield
spider-man as a professor i would love
to see both of these and i'm doing a
kick flip over the podium
since we were going to get a fourth toby
maguire sam raimi spider-man and never
did
one of the earliest spider-man comics i
did read was of spider-man getting
married to mj and having a daughter so
that would line up pretty well yeah and
it would be a happy conclusion for them
but something that they did say was that
uh norman osborne takes them to the oz
corp within their mcu so would that mean
there's already a norman osborn
established within the mcu as well
who's just been working in the
background all just a good guy that's
norman osborne yeah yeah he's just fine
yeah he doesn't have a son i guess the
plot leak goes on to say
through their connection to their home
universes the villains sense that their
spider-men
are likely on their way they use the
oscorp device to open
a one-way portal into the amazing
spider-man universe
with the amazing spider-man rhino
barging through the sinister six
are goblin awk sandman the lizard
electro and the rhino willem dafoe's
osborne realizes the way to
open two-way portals and thus get back
to their own universes
is to power the osborne device with a
stark power core
the green goblin ends up getting this
device while the other sinister six
distract the spider-man
allowing him time to get it from stark
industries the sinister six go to battle
with all
three spider-men at the statue of
liberty the green goblin plans on using
the statue of liberty to open portals
back to their own worlds
this is the second or third plot league
to have mentioned a
big battle at the statue of liberty so
that seems to be like a
very consistent thing we always we're
always honest whether or not we believe
a report or a leak
ever we're always honest we don't just
immediately buy it but they always sound
exciting anyway
to trap the spider-man here so they can
no longer interfere with their plans
in their own respective universes toby
maguire's spider-man is beaten way
harder than the other
younger spider-man and ends up dying
after the battle well this is where i
start to get kind of really
mad and upset because i definitely don't
want this to happen but i'll talk about
it more at the end
norman osborne's green goblin finally
shows up at the end with the device
and norman osborne activates the device
but they managed to stop him and protect
ned in a 2v1 fight with him
but the green goblin manager i don't
believe there's a spider-man with a
pumpkin bomb
and ends up killing ned another part
tom holland spider-man nearly kills the
green goblin but
andrew garfield spider-man stops him
from becoming a villain
like them the sinister six get locked
back up in strange's prison
and tom holland spider-man and andrew
garfield spider-man attend toby maguire
spider-man's funeral
in the raimi universe and then seemingly
part ways tom holland spider-man in the
mcu ends up turning himself
in but he ends up being successfully
defended from
murder charges by his lawyer matt
murdock
aka daredevil however his secret
identity issue
is not resolved as everybody still knows
that peter parker is spider-man
one of the final scenes is of tom
holland spider-man going up to ned's
grave and talks about how he feels
responsible for his death
it's at this point that andrew garfield
spider-man shows back up
in his universe and he gives the
responsibility talk to tom holland
spider-man
tom holland spidey realizes that ned
like uncle ben
tony stark and toby maguire's peter
parker would want him to still be a hero
it then says that the final swing is of
both tom
and andrew spider-man in the streets of
the mcu
new york
i don't believe it i i don't think they
would
kill off both toby maguire and ned
in the same i'm not gonna walking dead
this no
back to back i could see a version where
toby maguire the human
actor being like i want this to end
kill me off like a harrison ford
situation i could see
toby maguire kind of being that way i
don't believe it though i don't
especially when you're going to kill off
ned
on top of that i mean like i want more
of that dramatic
heft and weight that i felt in the rainy
films
i want that i don't know i can't see a
version where i like this
if that's the case and yeah ned too i
don't know i don't believe it yeah and i
don't think it's necessarily this
movie's job to give
that heavy of a wrap-up to the toby
maguire spider-man like
especially if you're going to introduce
he's got a married life and a daughter
and stuff like that i feel like
there's a better way to send him off
back home in a way that does end this if
he wants to be done with it but also
isn't quite so grim and if honestly the
way how this is all unfolding it would
make me hate tom holland's peter parker
a little because this is all like
his fault this is all like it's all
turning out into his fault because of
his decision-making and having to bring
them over i mean if it unfolds that way
and if the
if the execution is handled well i'll
come back and be like you know it
actually
unfolded the way this is
it did better than i expected right now
as it's being pitched i'm like
i i'm having a hard time really wrapping
my head around
this being true yeah now this pot leak
overall
sounds pretty cool i like how everything
is incorporated with the other two
universes i like the fact that the
multiverse is yeah the first half was
awesome
strange has already been doing a job
kind of protecting
the entire multiverse by locking up some
of the villains
now norman osborne is a genius and if
anybody as far as villains are concerned
are going to know how to open up these
portals it's going to be him
at least anybody that the mcu is
prepared to introduce
this also follows other leaks that we've
heard before that primarily involve
around the green goblin being the main
villain
which at this point in time many
different reliable insiders have
reported to be true
in fact last week daniel rpk backed up
the fact again that the green goblin is
the main villain if you consider the
fact that
multiverse of madness is coming right
after this it would make sense that the
madness would begin
in spider-man no way home now i actually
really like this plot leak but the only
part i
hate about it is the fact that toby
maguire spider-man would die this is
something that i just don't want to
happen he's my personal favorite
spider-man and i would hate
you now on screen especially if you just
showed him being married to mj
and having a daughter now it does make
sense that he would be
a little bit out of shape compared to
the other two younger spider-man but i
would really hate for him to die and i
think it would be a shame
the same thing goes for ned i don't hate
ned dying as much as i hate toby dying
because it wouldn't be the first time
that
spider-man in a movie lost a true best
friend toby lost harry
andrew garfield spider-man lost gwen it
would make sense that there is a loss
for
tom holland's peter parker don't like
the one two combos
yeah because one would overshadow the
other great
i think it could add to the future
movies but i think we'll have to see how
it's executed
but overall this plot leak actually
sounds pretty good now of course take it
with a grain of salt as always but if
the whole thing isn't true i definitely
think that there are parts of this that
are for sure true
but let me know what you think about
this and specifically let me know how
you would feel
if toby maguire spider-man died in
spider-man no way home
and ned and of course don't forget to
subscribe and hit the notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof thank you spider warren yeah i
would say that
uh warren took it so serious that he's
like listen
just make it black when i'm talking
about my feelings on
you just fill it in with your own
imagination of what you know toby
maguire would look like overshadowing
ned's death
that's what i mean it would it would
because even the way it warren said it
at the very end like you know toby
mcguire dying
and ned is like how people would
probably exactly yeah it would be it
would be more of a talk of that than it
would be ned yeah i don't like the idea
like if you're gonna kill off ned
it should just be ned if you're gonna
kill toby you should just be toby i
don't like the idea of killing off toby
after
reintroducing him like that if anyone
deserved it could have a more powerful
meaningful death it would be ned in the
moment anyway guys what do you think
about this crazy spider-man pot like
that is a crazy one i like the first
half a lot though
yeah like see where they're at in their
respective universes that's cool one of
all these it's the most
like in increments plausible sounding so
we're getting closer with these
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below thank you spider warren subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button
if you're annoyed that we keep covering
these why are you here
and thank you to all who keep
encouraging us to cover these keep
watching because these are a blast
thank you guys